it's it's being reported that there's a  delegation of your cabinet colleagues  waiting in downing street including the  chief whip the transport secretary and  your new chancellor  waiting to tell you when you finish here  today that it's time for you to go how  will you respond to that uh uh darren  darren  you're you're asking me to comment uh on  this conversation it's been in a few  minutes  uh but i i if you want to ask about uh  what we're doing to help people uh with  the cost of living if you want to ask  about what we're doing to build more  clean green energy supply which uh this  this committee has taken uh an interest  in that's going to be your answer to the  cabinet colleagues  i'm very happy to to talk to you about  it but i'm not going to give a a running  commentary on political events we're  going to get on with the government of  the country